>>
Good afternoon everyone, my name is Anthony
Ravitz, and I'm a member of Google's Real
Estate Workplace Services Team.
We're always working to create a healthier,
more sustainable work environment for all
of us here at Google.
And I'm honored to have the privilege to introduce
our guest today, Ray Anderson.
The first time I heard Ray speak was about
four years ago.
The first time that I attended Green Build,
the U.S. Green Buildings Counsels -- very,
very popular annual conference in Atlanta,
Ray's home state.
And Ray was a keynote speaker on the equally
inspiring Paul Hawken.
This journey began about 11 years before that
in 1994 when Ray read Hawken's book, The Ecology
of Commerce, and experienced what he has called,
"A Spear in the Chest"
It was then that he set himself and Interface
-- the carpet manufacturing company that
he had founded over 20 years earlier -- on
a completely new path to become the first
industrial corporation to seek sustainability.
Today, Interface calls that 'Mission Zero'
-- to eliminate any negative impact on the
environment by 2020.
These efforts have not only transformed Interface,
but revolutionized an entire industry -- a
really large industry.
Carpet runs cover an estimated 70 percent
of floors in the U.S. and approximately five
million pounds of carpet are discarded every
year.
Just in Google's Webold San Francisco office
where we reused as much of the existing carpeting
as possible, we still discarded and recycled
over 68,000 pounds or about seven garbage
trucks full of carpet.
That's a lot of carpet.
Ray's transformational work reaches far past
the carpet industry.
He published his first book, "Mid-Course Correction"
in 1999.
He has been featured in a slew of documentaries
including 'The Corporation' and Leonardo DiCaprio's,
the Eleventh Hour.
He serves as co-chairman of the President's
Counsel on Sustainable Development under Clinton
and, more recently, as an architect of the
Presidential Climate Action Plan, a hundred-day
action plan on climate that was presented
to the Obama Administration.
Ray has received more honors and awards for
his work than I can possibly begin to list.
Most recently, he has published his second
book, "Confessions of a Radical Industrialist."
Please join me in giving a warm welcome to
Ray Anderson.
>> [Clapping]
Ray Anderson: Thanks very much, Anthony and
Ruben -- very generous introduction.
Hello everybody, I'm Ray.
Greetings from Atlanta.
Funny way of talking, but bear with me.
Get into eventually.
Asked me if I'd be introducing myself.
I'm going to be saying something about I'm
a husband.
Father of two daughters, grandfather of five
terrific grandchildren, soon to be a great
grandfather, and I am an industrialist -- some
would say a radical industrialist.
And I promise you, each and every one, I am
as competitive as anybody you know, as profit-minded
as anybody you know or as likely to meet.
I founded my company, Interface, from absolute
scratch, from just an idea 36 years ago in
1973, to produce carpet tiles in America for
the emerging office of the future.
Today, the office of the future is here, and
carpet tiles are used around the world in
the most modern offices and hospitals and
schools and retail stores for their own use,
and hotels and you name it.
Interface makes about a third of all the carpet
tiles used on Earth, which is
a reasonable market share.
>> [laughter]
Ray Anderson: That handle 'radical industrialism'
did become incorporated into the title of
this book that I've just published with St.
Martin's press.
And I want to take a couple of themes from
the book today and develop them for these
remarks.
The title I would give these remarks however,
is not "Confessions of a Radical Industrialist",
I would give the title "The Corporation of
the Future: Reinventing the Industrial System."
And that is very much what the book is about.
So let me begin the two well-known quotes
from 47 years ago.
Quote, "We stand there where two roads diverge.
But unlike the roads in Robert Frost's familiar
poem, they are not equally fair.
The road we've long been traveling is deceptively
easy, but at its end lies disaster.
The other fork in the road -- the one less
traveled by -- offers our last, our only chance
to reach a destination that ensures for preservation
of the Earth." End quote.
Rachel Carson, Silent Spring, 1962.
35 years later, quote.
"Sustainable element is development that meets
the needs of the present generation without
sacrificing future generations' ability to
meet their needs." End quote.
The Brundtland Commission of the United Nations
1987, 22 years ago.
This afternoon, I want to expand the meaning
of those two quotes.
And I want to rely on the adage that "form
follows function", and I'm going to be ignoring
the form of the corporation of the future
to concentrate on its function.
There won't be anything here about legal or
organizational structure or governance issues.
There's no attempt to address the controversial
issue of personhood of the corporation, the
mischief that that might have caused through
the years.
I do make one assumption and that is that
capitalism will continue to set the framework
within which the corporation of the future
will function.
So I suggest that capitalism itself will have
to adapt.
I concentrate these comments -- as I do in
the book -- on corporations and big things:
What they do, and how they go about doing
it.
Furthermore, my focus is on the real economy,
not its rough analog, the financial markets
or their various indexes.
In other words, my focus is on the industrial
system, of which, we are each and every one
a part, either as producers or users or consumers.
For it is this industrial system -- this is
where the greatest challenges to environmental
sustainability lie.
Contemplating the corporation of the future,
one immediately is prompted to ask, "Well,
what future?"
Not to suggest that there won't be a future,
but to suggest that the future stretches far
into, well, the future.
So the question is -- and the important question
really is -- What time horizon are we addressing
when we say 'the future'?
Whether in the title of these remarks, The
Corporation of the Future, or in the Brundland
Commission's definition of sustainable development.
Indeed, what time horizon was the Brundtland
Commission contemplating when it offered its
definition of sustainable development?
Or let me frame the macro-issue of our times
as I see it this way.
We, individually and collectively -- that
is, humankind -- are an integral part of two
interrelated, intimately coexisting, global
systems.
Let us call one of these the 'technosphere'.
The other key component of the technosphere,
besides ourselves, is the industrial system.
It's the way we access raw materials, and
then make, transport, use, and discard things,
employing technologies across the full spectrum
of technology -- electrical, mechanical, construction,
mining, metallurgical, textile, nuclear, agricultural,
ceramic, automotive, biotechnological as well
as electronic, and semiconductor technologies
and any others that you can think of.
The technosphere, we, and the industrial system
coexist with the second global system -- the
biosphere.
The biosphere consists of all the natural
systems, living systems, and the life support
systems of the earth -- the forests, the rivers,
the oceans, the wetlands, the atmosphere to
the ozone layer, to the aquifers, to the crop
lands, the grasslands, the hydrologic cycle,
the carbon cycle, including photosynthesis,
climate regulation, pollination, seed dispersal,
flood and insect control, and so on and so
forth -- and all of life on earth, including
us.
By the way, you might try to picture the Earth
without any one of those elements of the biosphere.
So we have the technosphere, we have the biosphere,
and we have the co-existense of
the two within a thin, spherical shell with
8,000 miles in diameter -- the diameter of
the Earth -- and only about ten miles thick
extending from sea level, about five miles
from the depths of the ocean, about five miles
into the troposphere.
Notice that we humans are the common element
in both systems -- both spheres.
And relatively speaking, the thin shell is
the thickness of ceramic for the basketball-sized
Earth.
In this context, maybe the good or better
definition of 'sustainability' might be -- if
I can be so bold -- "The contingent, healthy,
balanced coexistence into the indefinite future
of the technosphere and the biosphere within
the thin shell."
Another name for the biosphere, of course,
is nature.
Yet, it's manifestly clear -- for anyone that
cares to look -- that this coexistence is
so unbalanced, so threatened, and it is not
healthy -- Rachel Carson's 'wrong road'.
On a global scale, every living system is
in decline -- biodiversity plummets, and extinction,
unprecedented in 65 million years, is underway
now.
The human footprint increases.
The planet's carrying capacity for humans
shrinks.
The planet warms.
The climate is disrupted.
The weather goes nuts.
The technosphere continues to expand at nature's
expense as the economy worships at the near-sacred
shrine of growth.
The question arises, "How can this go on and
on and on and on into the indefinite future?"
And the answer is clearly, "It cannot."
Unless we somehow miraculously find that the
Earth is infinite in its ability to supply
the stuff demanded by the technosphere and
infinite in its ability to absorb the poison
produced by the technosphere.
This imbalance, this dysequilibrium, is a
serious problem.
We've created, not only for ourselves, but
for our children and our grandchildren and
their grandchildren and beyond.
So how do we begin to reverse the negative
trends, eliminate this problem, and bring
these two systems -- technosphere and nature
-- into harmonious balance, in a way that
will last a thousand human generations, ten
thousand human generations -- that is to say,
indefinitely?
We should be very clear -- the longer we wait
to get started in earnest, the greater will
be the deficit that we and successive generations
have to overcome.
So I'm addressing the time horizon that extends
from now through a period of urgent, enormous,
and essential transformation to a state of
global equilibrium between biosphere and technosphere
in which the two will coexist in balance and
harmony, meaning the technosphere will be
taking from the biosphere no more than the
biosphere can naturally and rapidly renew
with energy input from the sun into the indefinite
future.
That, to me, is sustainability.
So how does the technosphere -- we in this
industrial system of ours -- move from its
present state to that ideal end state of equilibrium
and remain there into the distant future?
Well, let's begin to answer that question
by assessing where the industrial system is
now.
For starters, our society -- especially its
industrial system and essentially every corporation
anywhere -- is in the iron grip of Paul Andromic's
environmental impact equation.
I = P x B x T, from the Population Bomb, which
they published in 1997, in which I stands
for 'environmental impact', a negative term
-- the bigger, the worse.
P stands for population.
A for affluence, and T for technology in its
broadest sense as I just described it.
This equation says that environmental impact
-- or degradation -- is caused by people
-- the more, the worse.
What they consume in their affluence -- the
more, the worse.
And now, all of that is produced, used, and
disposed of -- the more technology, the worse.
So at the heart of the current and ongoing
environmental decline is this take/make/waste
industrial system.
Making and supplying the stuff that we humans
consume in our affluence and discard in our
thoughtlessness and technology too is a major
part of the problem.
So our affluence and population.
Population is a subject for another day, and
I make no effort here to deal with it nor
in the book, but I will get to affluence in
a little while.
But first, we must ask, What confines T to
the numerator where it contributes to the
problem instead of to the solution?
Why does T multiply negative impacts?
I suggest that this is because T in the numerator
accurately represents the technologists of
the first Industrial Revolution. Call them
T1.
We've grown up with these, and we take them
for granted.
Consequently, the problem in our society and
its industrial system is they share some common
attributes.
They are extractive -- they take from the
Earth.
They are linear -- take/make/waste.
Driven by energy from fossil fuels, wasteful
and abusive, and focused on labor productivity
-- more of everything per man hour.
So the Erlich equation could promptly be modified
to read I = P x A x T1 in high-tech terms,
1.0.
That describes our industrial system.
And I fairly suggest that the prevalence of
T1 arises from the flawed view of reality
that underlies the industrial system -- or
paradigm -- that traces its roots to the earliest
days of the Industrial Revolution in the 18th
century when people were the limiting factor
of production and nature was bountiful, seemingly
inexhaustible.
This is a view of reality that assumes -- or
acts as if it assumes -- that the Earth is
infinite in its ability to provide the stuff
to feed the industrial system's metabolism
and infinite in its ability to absorb the
system's waste no matter how much, no matter
how poisonous.
Relevant time frames for considering the consequences
of our individual decisions are very short,
almost _____ beyond our own lifetimes, more
likely now beyond our working lives.
And business long-range planning is maybe
five years.
Politics and then to the election.
Earth was made for humans to conquer and rule.
Homo sapiens don't really need those other
species, except for food and fiber, fuel,
and maybe shade on a hot summer day.
Adam Smith, Invisible Hand in the Market,
______.
Business exists to make a profit, the Milton
Friedman school of thought.
Throughout ______ to increasing labor productivity,
more everything per man hour.
It was natural enough to think this way in
the 18th century when people were scarce and
nature was bountiful, Why not use nature to
enhance human productivity?
It made perfect sense then, 300 years ago.
Technology, coupled with left-brained human
intelligence, practical, pragmatic, nonetheless
driven, results-oriented will see us through.
Though the 'I' part of the equation stands
in defiant contravention of this assumption.
There's more, but I expect you to get the
drift.
I suggest that the view of reality represented
by these beliefs is deeply flawed and it also
underlies the flawed system of economics that
begins by describing the basic economic problem
that drives all economic progress as the gap
between what we have and what we want -- not
need -- want.
This is the first lesson that Economics 101.
And economists tell us we can never close
that gap, because whatever we have, we will
always want more, and that that gap drives
all economic progress.
It's also insisted that worship at the shrine
of growth, without due consideration for what
should grow and what should not grow.
And it is a system that ignores the externalities,
the costs to society, and innocent third parties
that are inherent in so many of the transactions
that it fosters.
As it establishes prices solely on the basis
of supply and demand without regard for true
costs.
This, of course, renders the 'invisible hand'
blind as a bat in its allocation of resources
as it stumbles along in its blindness ignoring
the consequences of its actions that are represented
by the externalities it creates.
When we stand back and look at this system
and the mindset or the worldview that underlies
it, we cannot avoid the inevitable conclusion,
This system that takes from the earth whatever
it wants, to produce products that quickly
end up in landfills and incinerators -- think
of pollution -- wastes vast amounts of resources
all along the way, and does all of this with
total indifference to society's costs simply
cannot go on and on and on.
Its days of necessity are gone, because the
industrial system that stems from this worldview
is destroying the biosphere that undergirds
the system itself.
For you tell me, what company -- what economy
-- can survive without air, clean water,
food, energy, materials, climate regulation,
and ultraviolet radiation shield, pollination,
seed dispersal, flood and insect control,
water purification and distribution, the hydrologic
cycle, nutrient cycle, photo synthesis, and
more, all provided by nature?
Without any one of these, there would be very
little economy at all.
Nature, truly, is the goose that lays all
the golden eggs, and like the goose in Jack
and the Bean Stalk, Nature is being squeezed
to death.
If this is the state in which we -- the technosphere,
the industrial system, and ourselves -- find
ourselves, where must we go from here, and
how?
For starters, we must find a way to rewrite
the early impact equation, to break its iron
grip, and move technology to the denominator.
Then technology would reduce environmental
impacts and become part of the solution instead
of a major contributor to the problem.
The mathematically-minded will see it immediately
-- the bigger T becomes in the denominator,
the smaller the environmental impacts become.
But what must happen in society for such a
transformation to occur?
I suggest that the underlying mindset -- the
paradigm, the view of reality -- must change.
And you look -- flawed view born of the 18th
century, must be replaced by a new mindset
that acknowledges that the Earth is finite
as a source and we can see it from space -- that
is it.
Relevant time frames for considering the consequences
of our decisions are evolutionary in scale.
We must grow up as a species and learn to
think beyond our individual lifetimes and
our trivial self-interests.
Humankind was made for Earth, not the other
way around.
The Earth doesn't belong to us; we belong
to it.
And the diversity and vitality of nature are
crucially important in keeping the whole realm
of life, including us, going sustainably over
evolutionary time.
The blind, invisible hand of the market is
a dishonest, opportunistic broker.
It will force any cost on society that an
unwary or uncaring public will allow it to.
It must constantly be re-addressed to keep
it honest and give it sight.
Business exists to make a profit?
I beg to differ.
Business makes a profit to exist, not the
other way around.
And while sure, the existence of a higher
purpose, given this pervasive, global reach
in its power for good or evil, what CEO really
expects to stand before her or his Maker someday
and discuss shareholder value?
And what about technologies?
Technologies that are extracted, linear, take/make/waste,
driven by fossil fuels, wasteful abuses, focused
on labor productivity emanating from a flawed
concept are inherently unsustainable.
They do belong in the numerator where they
multiply and drive environmental degradation.
To move to the denominator and become part
of the solution, technologists must evolve
to become renewable, cyclical, driven by solar
energy, waste-free, benign, and focused on
resource productivity -- the efficient use
of all resources, not just labor.
I = [P x A] / T2.
This is the new test for the viability and
suitability of technologies in the sustainable,
industrial system and in the Corporation of
the Future.
Do you see how T2 technologists emulate nature?
How interesting.
Biomimicry at work on the very large stage
-- cyclical, renewable, waste-free, focused
on resource productivity -- that's the way
nature works.
These two T2 technologies can also put people
-- no longer scarce, but today an hopefully
abundant resource -- to work in ways that
conserve nature, which is now the scarce and
diminishing resource here in the 21st century.
For sure, the greatest moral and ethical and
practical challenge humankind faces is lifting
the poorest among us out of grinding poverty
-- the 4 billion poorest among us out of
grinding poverty -- while simultaneously repairing
an already badly damaged biosphere.
Resource efficiency.
The efficient use of all the resources is
the route to abundance for all for an indefinite
future on the finite Earth.
As for intelligence, what about right-brain
intelligence?
-- the subjective, the caring, the nurturing,
the artistic side of intelligence.
Perhaps it's a good bit more important than
the left side, since it also represents the
human spirit.
And therefore, the ascendancy of women in
business, in the professions, and in government
is one of the most encouraging of all trends,
as women bring their right-brain nurturing
nature to bear on the seemingly intractable
problems created by us left-brained men.
So, if society adopts this new mindset, how
does it then shape the Corporation of the
Future, indeed, the industrial system of the
future that will survive and thrive as an
integral component of the technosphere that
is in harmony and balance with the biosphere
into the indefinite future?
Well, that sounds downright utopian, doesn't
it?
Is it even possible?
Well, the answer to the question "Is it possible?"
is found at the microlevel, and the answer
is, "Yes, it is possible."
As Amory Lovins founder and chief scientist
of the Rocky Mountain Institute often says,
"If something exists, it must be possible."
I can quote Amory, because I speak here drawing
from the real life experiences of my company,
Interface -- an example of what is coming
into existence, what is proving to be possible.
And as for how -- in answer to the first question
-- the Interface experience is the result
of a plan for achieving zero environmental
footprint by the year 2020.
This is the plan that is transforming a typical,
petrol-intensive company, for energy and materials
of the 20th century into a prototypical sustainable
company of the 21st century.
How we get there is the main focus of "Confessions."
I suggest out of strong conviction that, if
Interface -- given its petroleum-intensive
nature -- can do it, any company can.
If any company can, it follows that every
company can.
That is to say, the entire industrial system
can.
Well, how did such a conviction originate?
In 1994, as Anthony said, inspired by Paul
Hawken's previous book, the Economy of Commerce,
I committed Interface to the path to sustainability
and to the plan for achieving it.
Fifteen years ago -- despite the enormous
challenge in having such an ambitious commitment
-- we began at Interface, where every company
must begin where we were, as part of a supply
chain that took materials and energy, both
fossil-derived, from the Earth, produced our
products in linear take/make/waste processes,
sold those products into a marketplace where
they served their purpose typically for ten
to 20 years, and then, were relegated to landfills
and incinerated -- long since forgotten by
us, their maker.
We first created a schematic showing all the
linkages of our company to the Earth -- it's
biosphere, it's lithosphere -- through our
suppliers, our customers, the communities
in which we operated, and directly through
our own people and processes and products.
I will not bore you with the details of the
schematic, but we ask ourselves 15 years ago,
"What is wrong with this picture?" We asked
this question when very few of any companies
anywhere were asking such a question of themselves.
And out of that question came the plan for
realizing a new vision to climb a very high
mountain clear to the top that pointed the
summit symbolizing 'zero impact'.
We call this now 'sustainability'.
The challenge is hugely daunting.
The commitment to reach the summit must be
equally unrelenting and unfaltering.
The goal: To operate our petrol-intensive
company so as to take from the Earth only
what the Earth can naturally and rapidly renew
and to do no harm to the biosphere.
To get off oil completely.
To get off coal completely.
And as we stood at this mountain for fully
a year, we identified seven faces of Mount
Sustainability, and we set out to climb each
face to its own peak.
And we hit the summit, which symbolizes "Zero
footprint, Zero impact by 2020." We call this
"Mission Zero".
The first face of the mountain is to eliminate
waste -- even the very concept of waste -- emulating
nature in our industrial processes.
In nature, there's no waste.
One organism's waste is another organism's
food.
The cost avoided by this effort through 2008,
some $205 million to date have funded the
entire Mountain Plan, rendering sustainability
self-funding.
The second face of the mountain is to ensure
totally benign emissions, working upstream
with suppliers to establish the strings that
eliminate all the harmful materials.
For whatever comes into our factories will
go out -- as product, solid waste or liquid
effluent or gases and emissions.
We will operate without smoke stacks and without
effluent pipes and for sure without toxic
or greenhouse gases that contribute to climate
disruption.
The third face in the mountain stop -- operate
on 100 percent renewable energy, concentrating
on energy efficiency first to drive energy
usage to that irreducible minimum and then
harnessing renewable sources of energy all
created verifiable offset to eliminate or
neutralize all greenhouse gas contribution
to global climate disruption.
The fourth face of the mountain is to close
the loophole material flows -- to capture
precious, energy-intensive hydrocarbon molecules
into their first part of life and give them
life after life and cyclical flows.
No more million take/make/waste processes
with the cyclical processes too driven by
renewable energy.
The technologies did not exist when we began
15 years ago, but now, they've fallen into
place one by one.
This is not a "flavor of the month" exercise.
It is a commitment of a lifetime.
The fifth face of the mountain is the transportation
face -- to transport people and products in
pollution-free, resource-efficient, climate-neutral
modes.
The sixth face is perhaps the most important
of all -- sensitizing stakeholders.
This is the culture shift.
This is changing the mindset that underlies
our presumption system -- and not just the
mindset of our own people, of our suppliers
and customers and communities.
Without such a shift in mindset, no lasting
changes will occur.
As Albert Einstein told us, "We cannot solve
our problems with the same thinking we used
to create them."
Overcoming -- vitally necessary new thinking
comes only out of a new mindset -- overcoming
the status quo.
"We've always done it this way."
It's hard, but it is essential.
And it does not happen without a willingness
to risk failure, but to learn from failure
and try again.
The seventh face of the mountain calls for
the redesign of commerce itself.
The new economy and the economy that seeks
to satisfy needs rather than wants, internalizes
the externality of the prices, gets the prices
right, and creates an honest, sighted market.
For many industrial companies like Interface
this will eventually translate into going
to market with the services that our products
rely on, rather than with the products themselves
-- creating products as a means to an end,
the end being satisfactory service delivered.
For Interface this translates into selling
color and texture and design and comfort underfoot
and good ____ control and cleanliness and
ambience and functionality, satisfying all
the reasons for which anyone would want our
carpets in the first place, while repaying
the ownership of the means of delivery.
Parenthetically, a chapter of Confessions
is devoted to each of the seven faces of the
mountain -- that's just discussing how you
actually do what I have just described.
Success on all seven faces of the mountain
will result in an entirely new schematic.
Again, I'll spare you the tedium of the schematics.
But, you can see -- there are no linkages
to the lithosphere -- to the raw materials.
And no linkages to the biosphere for waste
and emissions.
How is our real-life example doing?
How far has it come in 15 years on this 26-year-long
journey?
Well, the following 2008 eco-metric tells
the story.
Cumulative avoided waste costs, $405 million.
78 percent reduction in landfill waste, commuted
production.
Water intake down 74 percent.
Total energy usage down 44 percent per unit
of production.
Fossil fuel intensity reduced by 60 percent.
Net greenhouse gases reduced 71 percent in
absolute tonnage.
That translates into 82 percent reduction
in greenhouse gas intensity relative to sales.
28 percent of global energy from renewable
sources.
24 percent of total raw materials recycled
of bio-based materials.
One hundred percent renewable electricity
in our European factories -- 89 percent worldwide.
83 million square yards of climate-neutral
carpet produced since 2003, meaning climate
neutral from the well head and the mine cliff
to the end of life reclamation -- the full
life cycle.
Net zero on greenhouse gas emissions.
87,500 tons of reclaimed product, brought
back from our reentry effort to close the
loop of material flow.
So 191 million airline passenger miles offset
by the planting of some 98,000 trees, though
admittedly, there's a timeline while the trees
grow.
Overall footprint reduction, about 60 percent,
depending on how you weigh the individual
components of it.
In case you're wondering, "Can a company do
all this and not go broke?"
Save the last two metrics, sales up by 60
percent over the same timeframe spanning the
deepest, longest recession in our industry's
history in 2001 and 2003.
And profits double.
The business case is crystal clear; costs
are down, not up -- dispelling a myth in the
false ______ between the economy and the environment.
Waste elimination effort alone, $405 million,
has paid the way here.
Products have not only been -- ever, sustainable
design is a well-spring of innovation, especially
biomimicry.
And I'll give you an example of that later.
People are galvanized around the shared purpose.
You cannot beat attracting the best people
and bringing them together around a shared
purpose.
Goodwill of the marketplace -- greater than
any amount of advertising or clever marketing
at any cost could have created.
And believe me, we know that goodwill is earned
every day by doing, not by talking.
It is a better way -- a better way to bigger,
more legitimate profits -- a better business
model.
Better for the planet and better for the shareholder.
Now, coming back to the macro-case.
What about this sacred shrine of growth?
Moving toward a sustainable society, what
should grow, and what should not grow?
Well, here are some thoughts.
The lowest impact technologies -- those that
belong in the denominator -- should grow.
The abusive technologies -- those that belong
in the numerator -- should shrink and eventually
disappear.
The sale of services should grow; the sale
of products should shrink.
Applied brain power should grow; applied brute
force shrink.
Market shares for the sustainable companies
should grow; for the unsustainable companies,
market shares should shrink to zero.
At best, however, humanity faces a period
of transition in which the equation will read
I = [P x A x T1] / T2 where T1 represents
the unsustainable technologies, T2 the sustainable
technologies, and over time, T1 must give
way to T2, until eventually only T2 is left.
But, can humanity realize a sustainable society,
even if the entire industrial system eventually
operates within the revised, _____ equations,
I = [P x A] / T2?
I think not.
For affluence is still represented by capital
A in that equation suggesting that affluence
is an end in itself -- perhaps, the end.
And this just seems entirely too consistent
with the old definition of the basic economic
problem, The gap between what you have and
what you want.
What if, however, we homosapiens matured as
a species to the point that the basic economic
problem were redefined as the gap between
what we have and what we need?
What if that resulted from a reordering of
priorities for individuals and societies so
that affluence can be represented by a lower
case A instead of a capital A, suggesting
it to be a means to an end rather than an
end or the end in itself?
And what if the true end we all seek, "Happiness",
were injected into it and further revise early
equations?
It would then read I = [P x a] / [T2 x H]
-- more happiness with less stuff.
That would redefine, not only the industrial
system but civilization itself, as well as
capitalism and would open up the real possibility
for all human needs being met through a fair
and efficient use of all resources, meeting
the challenge to lift the four billion poorest
among us out of the grinding poverty, while
healing to the badly damaged biosphere.
But can the Corporation of the Future that
I have described survive and thrive among
such a reoriented set of societal priorities?
I suggest that only the Corporation of the
Future as I have described -- organized and
meet needs sustainably -- can survive in such
a reordered world into an indefinite future.
The typical corporation of the present will
be the proverbial "fish out of water", and
will surely suffer the same fate as that unfortunate
fish.
Environmental impacts must become vanishingly
small if humans even seven generations from
now -- much less 10,000 generations from now
-- are going to be born into a livable world.
Yet one might ask, "Isn't there a 'chicken
and an egg' problem here?" Will the transformed
society drive the transformation of the industrial
system, or will a transformed industrial system
drive the transformation of society?
And the answer is "yes" and "yes", for the
critical breakthrough mutations have already
occurred.
The chicken -- the new species of company
-- is being born right now.
So the two -- society and its new industrial
system -- can co-evolve to the higher plane
where equilibrium between technosphere and
biosphere is achieved at last.
And that, I believe, will create the foundation
for the new world order as well as the sustainable,
livable future for all generations to come.
Lastly, the variable population, P, remains.
But actually, may not be as independent a
variable as it seems in the equation.
The forces that give rise to modify affluence
and greater happiness -- in particular the
education of women around the world -- may
very well influence population to a lower
level than the current even projection of
some nine billion people indicates.
But, as I said in the beginning, that's a
discussion for another day.
So let's go back again to the micro-level.
Perhaps you're asking, "What does this look
like on your factory floor? What's it look
like in your design studio?
Show me sustainability in action.
What changes?" Okay.
Come with me and see what sustainability looks
like in just two examples in the time that's
left.
I tell you, engineers, production personnel,
and product designers collaborate to find
another way to create patterned carpet.
The conventional way -- employed for years
by the factory and its chief competitors -- is
to wet print carpet, wet print patterns on
a plain coat of carpet base.
Wet printing is water-intensive and energy-intensive,
requiring an aqueous dye application, high
energy staining to fix the dye to the fabric,
washing to remove the excess unfixed dye,
and energy-intensive drying to remove the
wash water.
Excess dye and wash water also require chemical
treatment before being released into the waterways.
But new thinking -- what Einstein was talking
about -- suggests that the temping machine
that forms the power face of the carpet in
the first place as untapped potential to precisely
put tufts of yarn on selected colors that
form bright, intricate, and more durable patterns.
So the mode of conception is right, to burn
the bridges and abandon wet printing altogether
to scrap the existing strain of investment.
After only one means of creating patterns
which the marketplace demands, development
efforts resulted in entirely new families
of patented inventions giving them the factory
proprietary edge rather than handicap in this
marketplace.
Drastic reduction in resource consumption
of both water and energy.
One of those patented inventions arises from
the outrageous, ridiculous assignment by the
head of design to his design team to go into
the forest and see how nature would design
the floor covering.
"And don't come back with leaf designs," he
says.
"Come back with nature design principles."
The head of design has read Biomimicry, by
Janine Benyus.
Biomimicry -- nature as teacher; nature as
inspiration; nature as mentor; nature as measure.
So the design team spent some days studying
on the forest floors in the stream beds, and
they finally come to realize, "There's total
diversity here -- even chaos.
No two things are alike."
No two sticks, no two leaves, no two stones,
no two squares yards of the forest floor are
the same.
Yet there's a pleasant orderliness in this
chaos.
So the designers go back to the design studio.
They design carpet tile such that the face
designs of no two tiles are identical.
Although similar, but every one is different
from all the others.
Now, how contrary is this to the prevailing,
industrial paradigm that every master fiber
needs to be cookie-cutter same, six sigma,
in the formula?
The new product is introduced to the market
with the name, "Entropy", scientific term
suggesting disorder.
And in a year and a half, it moves to the
top of the bestseller list, faster than any
other product ever has, and quickly becomes
the largest selling property tile in the district
of the industries.
The advantages of breaking the old paradigm
-- this insistence on perfection and sameness
-- are surprisingly humorous.
There's almost no waste, no lost quality in
production.
Inspectors cannot find defects among them.
[laughter] Deliver imperfection -- no two
tiles alike.
The installer can install now very quickly
without having to take the traditional care
to get the power map all running uniformly
-- the less uniform the better.
So he can just take tiles out of the box the
way they come and install them randomly.
There's almost no scrap during installation,
even a piece tile can find a place in the
installation.
And then, the user can actually rotate -- can
replace an individual damaged tile on the
floor without creating that silicon effect
that so typically comes with everything in
uniform and the new that's placed among the
old -- so the thumb.
Furthermore, there are no longer issues of
dye lots.
Dye lots emerged indistinguishably, which
obviates the need for shelf stock, and those
original tiles of the dye lot on the shelf
where you can be used.
And now, the user can even rotate the carpet
tiles on the floor to equalize where the way
you rotate tiles on my automobiles and makes
the length of replacement of damaged areas.
All of this is good for the environment through
increased resource efficiency.
Nature, the inspiration, is anything but cookie-cutter
uniform.
She knows nothing about six sigma, yet she's
very effective and a great teacher.
And still, even with all of the unexpected
benefits of entropy, one wonders is there
still more to explain the success?
Well, perhaps there is.
A speaker on the environmental speaking circuit
begins every speech by having her audience
close their eyes, and in their minds' eye,
picture their own ideal place -- their own
comfort zone -- that ideal place of peace
and repose and tranquility, serenity, creativity,
perfect comfort zone.
We might try it here. Humor me.
Everybody close your eyes, and in your mind's
eye, picture your ideal place of peace and
repose and tranquility, serenity, comfort
-- your perfect comfort zone.
You got it?
Now lift your hand high if you're somewhere
outdoors.
[chuckle] Look around you.
We humans gravitate to nature for that ideal
comfort zone.
I've done this 500 times around the world,
and in no population does it vary.
It's 90 percent plus of the audience raise
their hands.
We humans gravitate to nature, and somehow
I think if we take outdoors/indoors in a subliminal
way, that is just real appeal.
Sustainability in action.
I think Einstein would be pleased.
I'm out of time, and I thank you very much
for being here.
You've been a terrific audience.
It's time for questions.
I'm happy to take them.
>> [Clapping]
Q Thanks for letting me go outside in my mind.
I really like what you're saying here.
I wonder about getting there from here, of
course.
And something that I'm really concerned about
is the kind of -- the short-term, financial
decision making that can often stymie such
transformation.
I think you've made some good points that
there are sort of this false -- in many cases
-- assumption that sustainability equals
less profit, and that there are times where
you can make more profit by making more sustainable,
however, seems like a tough sell to a lot
of people who manage money.
Is this compatible with our notions of fiduciary
responsibility to shareholders etc.?
A Show of hands is absolutely yes.
What we are learning at Interface is that,
indeed, it is a better way.
And key to this better way, of course, is
the support of the marketplace.
We operated in a marketplace that's heavily
influenced by interior designers and architects
-- people who really want to do the right
thing.
So, in a sense, we were in a microcosm of
the much larger market, but it's dominated
by people who really do want to do the right
thing -- or heavily influenced.
So the name of the game is to spread that
awareness that exists in the architecture/interior
design community to get to the population
in general.
So, ultimately, the power is with the people.
When Jeffrey Immelt, the CEO of General Electric,
commits to doubling his R and D from 750 million
a year to a billion and a half of clean technologies
expected the government's revenue from ten
billion to 20 billion in the sale of those
clean technologies, there's not an ounce of
altruism in that.
He heard his customers.
It's like, "We need these technologies."
And when the public wakes up to what a hell
of a mess the Earth is in, and begins to demand
that every product, then you know, the marketplace
is supporting the movement.
Deepak Chopra has a way of saying, "People
are doing the best they can, given their level
of awareness."
This is all about raising level of awareness
and spreading that raised level of awareness
throughout the population.
We're in a race against time.
We literally are.
Put it this way.
The First Industrial Revolution still goes
on. Okay?
Extractive, abusive, waste, and that's Thomas
Newcomen's revolution.
He started it in 1712 when he invented the
steam-driven pump to pump water out of the
English ____ mines so miners could mine more
coal.
The Second Industrial Revolution that I'm
referring to here in the comments is Rachel
Carson, revolution she started in 1962.
And here we are 47 years into Rachel Carson's
revolution.
When we were 47 years into Thomas Newcomen's
revolution, the cotton gin had not yet been
invented.
So it's really early days revolution's gun
but the problem is we don't have the time.
We don't have the luxury of time for this
revolution to unfold.
It's incumbent on all of us to push the boy
as high as we can, as quickly as we can.
Yes?
Q Thanks for your talk.
Could you tell me what you would do as a CEO
in an auto industry?
Maybe name a few of the things that you'd
go after, examples of changes you put those
teams to work in?
A Well, it clearly would have taken a new
kind of thinking ten, 15 years ago in that
industry.
And I wouldn't preclude to know anything about
the automobile industry, except that you can
look around and you see examples of who stole
the march on whom.
And Toyota most certainly did, without going
after the happening technology dominating
that field today.
So the things that could be done ought to
have been done 15 years ago, and now they're
down a deep hole and dig out of it.
It's just that simple.
And I suspect that only those who are really
thinking about their business very differently
will survive.
But I don't know what that different thinking
actually means.
Q You commented about awareness being a function
of making the change and you know in ____
economic system almost every economic decision
also comes down to money.
And if you don't have the awareness, then
sometimes price is a good substitute in order
to encourage people to make that awareness.
How do you make this change relatively obvious
so it scales faster?
A Yeah. I really think government has a role
to play.
In my mind, government's the greatest power.
It's not just regulatory power, which is vast
and it runs the way we are for good.
But its greatest power is its taxation and
subsidy power.
And we very much need for government to get
involved to put a price on carbon, especially
with respect to global climate disruption.
Carbon has had a free ride forever, and we
all know that there's no such thing as a free
lunch.
So we pay for carbon, but in an indirect way.
It's like rising sea levels and the dikes
that have to be built to protect Miami and
New York City in the future.
And the price of wars in the Middle East to
put back the oil in the source and so on so
forth.
The externalities are there. We're paying
for them.
We need to be paying for those directly through
the price of carbon.
And then, that would put our minds where the
problem really is and would level the playing
field between the new technologies and the
old.
And you would see the new technologies surge
if there were a level playing field and fossil
fuels were priced properly.
Q So this is the end of Ray's talk, but if
you'd like to join us for lunch, we're going
to go to Charlie's Cafe.
So with that, thank Ray for joining us today.
>> [Clapping]